[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le 7-8 week-end
sur tv 60,18 voici le sommaire de ce 11
mars est deuxième et dernier jour pour
le sommet européen qui se tenait au
château de versailles emmanuel macron
réunissaient les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement européens depuis jeudi en
pleine guerre d'ukraine est l'événement
s'est clôturé ce vendredi après une
longue nuit de discussions premier bilan
à suivre il fera sa rentrée en septembre
2022 le campus cézanne est un site dédié
à la formation professionnelle à mantes
la jolie l'établissement est en lieu et
place de l'ancien collège paul cézanne
vide de ses élèves depuis quelques mois
et puis retour sur l'actualité de la
semaine avec notamment la venue d'
emmanuel macron à poissy le président de
la république sortant a effectué dans
les yvelines son premier déplacement
officiel en vue de la présidentielle
et je vous le disais à l'actualité de ce
vendredi marquée par la fin de ce sommet
européen qui se tenait pendant deux
jours au château de versailles et nous
retrouverons sur place dans un instant
notre journaliste amie qu'elle est ni
d'euros pour un premier bilan un sommet
bien sûr marqué par cette actualité et
le conflit en ukraine et dans cette
actualité le département des yvelines a
voté une aide ce vendredi deux cent
mille euros débloquée en faveur du
peuple ukrainien cette somme est remise
à l'eau à alger française pour soutenir
l'envoi de convois humanitaires vers
l'est de l'europe et vous le voyez une
aide inquiet voté par le département des
yvelines dont voici quelques archives
l'ouverture également d'une plateforme
d'accueil des réfugiés ukrainien dans le
département le préfet des yvelines jean
jacques brot additionner l'association
aurore pour ce faire elle la plateforme
et téléphoniques dans un premier temps
et réservée aux ressortissants
ukrainiens présent dans les yvelines aux
collectivités et associations
trois missions répondre aux
interrogations des réfugiés sur le
logement le droit au séjour les droits
sociaux la santé la scolarisation à
parier les offres aux besoins de
logements sur le territoire pour les
communes et les associations
enfin sur une coordination de tous les
services la plateforme est joignable du
lundi au vendredi de 9h 18h et d'ici une
dizaine de jours l'association aurore
ouvrira également un accueil physique à
versailles et développer des cursus de
formation professionnelle dans le nord
du département c'est l'objectif du
campus cézanne de mantes-la-jolie
installé dans les locaux de l'ancien
collège du même nom le site commence à
accueillir ses premiers élèves en vue
d'une véritable rentrée qui aura lieu en
septembre 2022 un partenariat entre la
ville et le département ainsi qu'avec la
chambre des métiers et de l'artisanat
des yvelines le reportage de mélanie
poquet plus de dix mille mètres carrés
bientôt 100% dédié à la formation vide
ses élèves partis étudier dans le
nouveau collège du val fourré
l'établissement se tourner vers la
formation professionnelle
principalement pour les décrocheurs
scolaires les bénéficiaires du rsa et
les demandeurs d'emploi nous sommes tous
convaincus que par l'éducation mais par
la formation
nous pourrons vaincre à vue
l'exclusion et le chômage de masse des
jeunes issus des quartiers politique de
la ville vient de voir des institutions
nous propose aux jeunes des solutions
qui leur soient adaptés il ya
différentes formes d'intelligence il ya
des intelligences plus conceptuel et des
intelligences plus pratique travaillons
sur toutes ces intelligences un projet
développé aussi grâce à un partenariat
avec la chambre des métiers de
l'artisanat des yvelines pour développer
une offre dans le nord du département
une formation coiffure a débuté à la
rentrée 2021 en septembre 2024 autres
secteurs vont être proposés nous avons à
la chambre de métiers de versailles un
cfa qui tombe déjà 700 crs 750 jeunes et
le président bédié nous a fait une
proposition ici nous animons témoins cf
avait un mental joly on a réfléchi quand
je vous le disais 25% des jeunes
viennent de montage ni parler à
versailles pas forcément simple nous
avons des maîtres d'apprentissage et
nous avons des professeurs qui peuvent
venir le signe aussi des associations
vont aussi progressivement prendre place
dans le site pour qu'il devienne à lui à
part entière dans le quartier budget
pour la mise aux normes du site un
million huit
fin de la semaine dans les yvelines où
une fois encore l'actualité a été très
dense ce qu'il faut retenir en 78
secondes c'est avec wilfrid richy
[Musique]
l'actualité de cette semaine marquée par
le premier rendez vous de campagne
présidentielle d'emmanuel macron un
déplacement à poissy pour une rencontre
avec 250 habitants devant un public à
qui il a notamment évoqué suppression de
la redevance audiovisuelle ou encore la
création d'un chèque alimentaire face à
une prochaine envolée des prix en marge
de ce déplacement lundi se tenait aussi
dans les yvelines le départ de la
deuxième étape du paris nice après une
première journée à mantes-la-ville la
course cycliste s'est élancé d'auffargis
la direction orléans depuis plus de dix
ans le département et partenaire de la
société aso organisatrice de l'événement
mardi 8 mars journée internationale des
droits des femmes et dans le département
l'occasion d'inaugurer à versailles un
nouvel accueil de jour dédié aux femmes
victimes de violence c'est la onzième
structure de ce type dans les yvelines
alors que la guerre perdure en ukraine
après les offensives russe la solidarité
s'organise à voisins le bretonneux une
famille accueille déjà des premiers
réfugiés femmes et enfants la france
envisage l'arrivée de cent mille
personnes depuis l'ukraine la guerre en
ukraine au coeur du sommet européen
versailles qui s'est tenue en fin de
semaine prévue de longue date cette
rencontre finalement bousculé par le
conflit a été l'occasion d'aborder les
questions de défense de l'union encore
de sa dépendance énergétique et pour
terminer cette semaine une note plus
légère avec le retour du festival
électro chic dans l'agglomération de
versailles grand parc concerts et
rencontres avec le monde de l'électro
pendant plus d'une semaine après deux
années d'organisation compliquée avec la
crise de la corrida
[Musique]
et vous l'avez vu l'une des actualités
de la semaine c'est ce premier
déplacement de la campagne
présidentielle pour emmanuel macron
président de la république sortant qui
est venu donc à poissy s'était elle
lundi dernier pour une conversation face
à des habitants une conversation qui a
duré un peu plus d'une heure trente
trois cent cinquante personnes dans
cette salle et du centre de diffusion
artistique de poids si on va revenir sur
ce premier déplacement de campagne avec
mon invité youssef sakr qui est avec moi
par visioconférence bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le directeur pédagogique de l'école
supérieure des professions immobilières
alors si on vous reçoit c'est que vous
étiez présents dans cette salle du
centre de diffusion artistique et vous
avez même pu poser une question à
emmanuel macron va y revenir dans un
instant déjà comment s'est organisé
cette participation comment vous vous
êtes retrouvé à a posé une question au
président de la république
de s'être en cours forcément elle et des
élus et à leur tête le maître de maire
de poissy karl olive
a sollicité les citoyens de poissy pour
les inviter à à suggérer des questions
et sur le panel des questions un certain
groupe semble avoir été sélectionné pour
garantir à la fois une vision à 360° des
questions que peuvent se poser les
pisciacais et faire en sorte pour
paraphraser car le développeur de poissy
que le questionnement dans sa diversité
y compris en termes de profil soit
révélateur de la diversité des
interrogations on hésite à l'esprit des
attentes des français à d'échelle du
territoire et à ce titre
j'ai donc suggéré d'interroger le
président de la république sur le sur le
jeu de l'éducation ont justement on va
écouter la question vous avez posées au
président de la république
je ne suis pas là en tant que militant
mais en tant que citoyen engagé
convaincu que la politique est un sujet
trop sérieux pour laisser le monopole au
parti quel qu'il soit par ailleurs donc
ma question porte sur
l'éducation si nous voulons promouvoir
et conforter l'apprentissage comme
filières d'excellence et vecteur
d'insertion professionnelle
l'école peut-elle encore exercer un
monopole de fait dans la conception des
programmes de formation dans le même
ordre d'idée si nous voulons continuer à
décloisonner et à libérer toutes les
énergies en faveur de l'éducation
comment promouvoir et impliquer
davantage le monde de l'entreprise comme
partenaires académiques et pédagogiques
auprès de nos écoles tous cycles
confondus voici un extrait de cette
question était justement question
d'éducation d'apprentissage pourquoi
vous avez voulu poser cette question là
au président de la république parce que
l'éducation était allongé mayor
j'ai écouté avec beaucoup d'intérêt
beaucoup d'attention l'intervention de
monsieur bédié au regard du projet que
vous présentiez que d'offrir ans et
pendant ce nouveau campus il faisait
allusion à l'éducation comme comme
vecteur d'intégration comme vecteur
d'accélération en termes d'ascension
citoyenne et sociale il faisait allusion
à la pluralité des intelligences auquel
doit correspondre une pluralité
diversité de réponses en termes d'offre
de formation plus globalement moi je
pense qu'on est dans une économie
globalisée de la connaissance avec de
grands enjeux le président évoquait en
disant qu'il s'agit non seulement de
répondre question qui se pose
aujourd'hui mais dans une logique de
prospective proposer des réponses qu'ils
soient encore en phase avec la france de
2030 il est fondamental d'être dans
l'anticipation
donc l'éducation c'est un enjeu majeur
la question qui était la belle était
motivée par le par le fait que
finalement emmanuel macron il ya de cela
cinq ans que les at il proposé il nous a
proposé de
nous libérer des clans des parties de
décloisonner de libérer les énergies de
changer de paradigme
donc j'ai estimé que pour s être
accueillant c'était fondamental
d'appréhender l'enjeu de l'éducation
avec cet état d'esprit nous pensons
aussi louer de façon cloisonnée
mais en invitant autour de la table tous
les acteurs susceptibles de favoriser de
conforter cette ambitieuse cette
ambition stratégique en termes
d'éducation l'école certes comme acteurs
institutionnels légitime d'ailleurs
qu'ils soient privés ou publics mais
aussi l'entreprise parce que quel que
soit le parcours de formation il y a une
finalité avant d'exercer en tant que
journaliste vous avez fait des études de
journalisme
mais les études en question n'était pas
une fin en soi il
a été anticipé on va dire la nécessité
que vous soyez légitime que vous soyez
crédible et que vous puissiez mettre en
cohérence les compétences dont vous
pouvez vous prévaloir avec les demandes
légitimes de votre employeur donc et ça
ça s'anticipe n'attendons pas d'être à
la fin d'un cursus pour constater et
parfois il est déçu que les compétences
pour lequel il a été préparé ben
finalement le match pas ne correspondent
pas assez avec avec l'entreprise quelle
qu'elle soit c'est un banc de l'avant le
premier coup de crayon de mon point de
vue qu'il convient d'intégrer de
consulter d'écouter la finalité de tout
parcours académique et de formation
c'est à dire l'entreprise avec un grand
e de tous secteurs confondus 4 soit
public ou privé c'était la motivation de
la question est le préalable quand je
disais à monsieur le président de la
république candidat je n'étais pas
présent contre le mérite non mais en
tant que citoyen engagé c'est à dire que
l'on peut comment dirais-je ou peut être
engagée on peut s'emparer de sujets
politiques sans pour autant être encarté
sans pour autant faire partie d'un dans
l'appareil si j'ose dire et là aussi ça
rejoint le l'esprit l'ambition la
singularité présidentielle incarné par
emmanuel macron qui par définition pas
transcende toutes les parties pour pour
épouser le parti multi m celui des
intérêts de notre pays alors sur
l'éducation plusieurs mesures en tout
cas
et bien mesure de campagne a annoncé un
notamment celle de parler d'orientation
un peu plus tôt aussi dans le cursus à
parler d'orientation dès la cinquième il
a évoqué aussi la question du sport à
l'école mettre un peu plus de sport à
l'école 30 minutes de sport par jour et
sur l'apprentissage dont on parlait il
ya un instant poursuivre cet objectif à
un million d'apprentis avec notamment la
grande réforme du lycée professionnel
c'est ce qui a été évoqué où la question
de la rémunération des jeunes vous
parliez aussi de cette question vous
avez posé non pas comme militant mais
plutôt comme citoyen sur la forme il a
été il a été dit après après cette
rencontre que finalement les questions
étaient très polis parfois préparés que
la salle était acquise pour pour
emmanuel macron qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de répondre à ces critiques qui
ont qui ont émergé après 7,7 rencontre
avec avec les citoyens
merci de poser la question parce qu'elle
offre de l'offre le porter en tout cas
de rétablir de mon point de vue la
réalité des faits
c'est quand même extraordinaire on
reproche à à des citoyens qui acquiert
qui accueille notre président de la
république qui étofferont est sur tous
les fronts de l'accueillir avec des
applaudissements ça n'est pas le
candidat qui a été accueilli avec des
applaudissements
c'est notre président au front depuis
plusieurs semaines pour veiller à notre
sécurité collective et qui s'investit
quasiment depuis cinq ans chaque jour
pour mériter notre confiance et nous
aurions de l'accueillir avec des
quolibets le président le mérite du
respect on peut être à la fois dans la
critique dans l'opposition mais pour que
celles ci soient
constructives je pense que les tic ethic
fondamentale impose la courtoisie quelle
que soit la légitimité du fonds
si la forme n'y est pas mais ça nous
tire tous collectivement vers le bas
premièrement deuxièmement vous faisait
allusion aux quelques 250 ainsi hacker
présent
les pisciacais présents étaient
représentatifs de la diversité
des quarante mille âmes qui ont le
privilège de vivre dans la cité saint
louis et
sauf erreur en 2017 on ne peut pas dire
que macron effet 100% à poissy donc ne
confondent pas le courtoisie éthique
républicaine
et on va dire fanatisme ou aveuglement
ou forme de subjectivité
acquise ça c'est mon point de vue
ensuite je ne vais pas faire semblant
d'être en désaccord si je suis en phase
avec mon interlocuteur sont les
fondamentaux ça n'empêche pas que nous
ayons des divergences mais dès lors que
ce qui nous rassemble en terme de points
de vue est plus important que ce qui est
susceptible de nous diviser nous reste
dans l'opposition sans être dans la
rupture on construit ensemble quelque
chose c'est voilà je tenais à apporter
ce bonheur des enfants
très sincèrement je pense que laissait
entendre que alors oui j'ai plus de 10
ans 11 ans d'expérience dans
l'enseignement supérieur
professionnalisant humilité mais à part
j'estime être une référence en france
mais c'est me faire trop d'honneur que
de considérer que la question que j'ai
posée au président de la république
était d'un niveau de complexité de
thèmes qu'il lui fallait se préparer
pendant deux jours pour pouvoir y
répondre
soyons sérieux
soyons sérieux un tout petit instant
pendant cinq ans notre opposant la
république a démontré sa capacité à
entrer dans le détail des sujets et
d'ailleurs dès les premiers débats en
l'occurrence avec marine le pas de
l'espoir
démonstration a été faite que il n'était
pas dans l'approximation de la maîtrise
des sujets et des enjeux et depuis le
premier jour de son mandat
il en a fait à chaque fois
l'illustration il est en pleine
immersion depuis des semaines et des
mois dans des enjeux et géopolitique
d'une intense complexité que le commun
des mortels n'arrive même pas à imaginer
et à côté de ça il y aurait fallu 48
heures pour se préparer à la question
qui lui était posée sur le sujet il
aurait fallu que 48 heures pour se
préparer à la question relative aux
enjeux relatifs à l'intégration des flux
migratoires ça n'est pas très sérieux
et focaliser sur l'essentiel quoi la
qualité de sa réponse et là je vous
donnais ma perception objective sur la
réponse qu'il m'a été donné alors 20
secondes si c'est possible on arrive à
la fin de cet entretien elle est
absolument j'ai eu le privilège d'être à
mettre du président de la république je
les regardais dans les yeux de me
regarder dans les yeux j'estime qu'il a
répondu à ma question avec un bémol je
pense que
la réflexion relative à l'ouverture
entre guillemets dieu tu me le pôle de
fait exercé par le milieu éducatif on va
dire public dans la conception de
programmes de formation mérite d'être
réalité roger et c'est avec plaisir que
je contribuerai à cette réflexion
opérationnel si le privé l'âge m'ont été
proposées
merci youssef cinq heures juste pour
précisions on dira quoi aussi la
question du pouvoir d'achat a bien sûr
été évoquée pendant cette conversation
avec en toile de fond bien sûr la guerre
en ukraine qui a qui est dans toutes les
têtes des mesures qui ont été annoncées
la suppression de la redevance
audiovisuelle la mise en place d'un
chèque alimentaires aussi un dispositif
pour accompagner les français dans les
os actuel du carburant merci en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce retour
merci pour votre habitation et je
rappelle vous étiez donc présents dans
la salle face à emmanuel macron et vous
êtes le directeur pédagogique de l'école
supérieure des professions immobilières
et dans l'actualité vous dire également
que trois versaillais ont été décorés de
la médaille d'honneur de la ville de
versailles une cérémonie se déroulait
mercredi dernier à la salle des fêtes de
la commune jacqueline fleury marié s'est
engagé dans la résistance à seulement 17
ans au cours de la seconde guerre
mondiale elle sera arrêtée puis déportée
après le conflit elle participe à la
création du concours national de la
résistance et de la déportation a été
également récompensé le général françois
meyer à gauche sur la photographie qui a
lui sauvé plus de 300 harkis pendant la
guerre d'algérie en désobéissant aux
ordres il les a aidés à rejoindre la
france est à même le vrai pour leur
reconversion en agriculteur en lozère
l'homme s'est ensuite être déployée est
employé à entretenir la mémoire de ses
anciens compagnons d'armes enfin le
colonel gonzalez donc à droite sur cette
photographie a toute sa vie servi sa
patrie il est parti combattre en tunisie
en italie et en allemagne pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale aux
fonctionnaires en indochine puis à alger
avant effectué une brillante carrière
dans le civil
votre rubrique elle légale checking à
présent pour vérifier ce que disent les
acteurs de l'actualité c'est avec le
collectif et des surligneurs chaque
vendredi dans le 7-8 week-end ce
vendredi raphaël mata est de vigneault
décrypte pour nous une proposition du
candidat communiste à la présidentielle
fabien roussel
fabien roussel soin de fermer les écoles
privées hors contrat car selon lui on ne
sait pas ce qui s'y passe qui enseigne
ce qui est enseigné et parce que l'état
n'aurait aucun moyen de contrôle sur
elle autant d'affirmations juridiquement
force que les contrôles sur ces écoles
soit défaillant c'est un fait mais en
droit il n'existe bien déjà une école
hors contrat ne peut ouvrir sans s'être
déclarée trois mois avant ce délai
durant lequel le maire le préfet le
recteur ou le procureur de la république
peut s'y opposer de plus la déclaration
doit être obligatoirement comportait de
nombreux détails tant sur le personnel
comme par exemple quasi judiciaire que
sur le fonctionnement interne de cet
établissement
ensuite le code de l'éducation précise
que si ces écoles sont libres dans le
choix des méthodes et des programmes
d'enseignement elles doivent avant tout
respecter l'obligation de la maîtrise du
socle commun de compétences et de
connaissances tels que déterminés par la
loi enfin le contrôle de ces classes et
déjà prévu et est assuré par les
inspecteurs de l'éducation nationale et
en cas de non respect des obligations
légales la fermeture de ces
établissements peut être prononcée ce
qu'il déjà le fait ou aujourd'hui par
ailleurs la fermeture pure et simple de
ces établissements irait à l'encontre de
la liberté de l'enseignement consacré
tant par la constitution que par la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme ou par la charte des droits
fondamentaux de l'union européenne ainsi
la loi française prévoit que
l'instruction obligatoire peut être
donnée soit dans les établissements
publics ou privés soit dans les familles
par les parents ou par toute autre
personne de leur choix par conséquent
l'état doit respecter le droit des
familles de choisir un enseignement
respectueux de leurs convictions sous
réserve évidemment de respecter l'ordre
public au final fabien roussel a le
choix soit imposé un régime
d'autorisation préalable et non plus une
simple déclaration renforçant ainsi le
contrôle a priori sur les établissements
soient rendre le contrat obligatoire
imposant ainsi à l'état de prendre en
charge le salaire des enseignants
solution qui lui conviendra probablement
pas
et direction tout de suite le château de
versailles je vous le disais en début
d'édition où se tenait le sommet
européen pendant deux jours emmanuel
macron a réuni les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des 27 pays de l'union
européenne on retrouve sur place vous le
voyez elle nicolas landry de la
rédaction de tv 78 qui se trouve dans la
salle de presse de cet événement avec
nicolas une conférence de presse de
conclusion qui s'est terminée il ya
quelques minutes
bonjour d'ailleurs effectivement la
conférence de presse finale s'est
conclue il ya quelques minutes ce sommet
européen de versailles restera dans les
annales du projet européen voilà comment
le président du conseil européen
charles michel a commencé son propos
lors de cette conférence de presse une
conférence de presse qui se déroulait
dans la galerie des batailles du château
de versailles avec emmanuel macron et la
présidente de la commission européenne
ursula von der leyen la souveraineté
européenne a été au coeur des
discussions pendant ces deux jours sur
fond de guerre en ukraine emmanuel
macron a déclaré durant cette conférence
de presse que c'était un impératif
aujourd'hui alors plusieurs mesures ont
été annoncées dans ce sens d'abord sur
l'énergie la sortie de la dépendance
vis-à-vis de la russie concernant le gaz
et le pétrole d'ici à 2027 la commission
européenne a reçu un mandat pour faire
des propositions d'ici la mi mai
d'ici quinze jours aussi il faudra se
doter de nouveaux mécanismes pour éviter
et résister aux chocs des prix de
l'énergie ça c'est les mesures d'urgence
dont elle a évoqué le président de la
république emmanuel macron il a été
aussi question de la défense européenne
hélas les trois protagonistes dirigeants
européens ont annoncé qu'il faudra faire
des investissements stratégiques
autour de l'industrie de la défense il a
été aussi question d'accueil des
réfugiés deux millions de refuge et
ukrainiens seront accueillis dans
l'union européenne et peut être plus
enfin les dirigeants les trois
dirigeants de repère aussi annoncé et
confirmé que si la russie intensifié ses
attaques voire même à siéger kiev eh
bien ils n'hésiteraient pas à imposer un
quatrième volet de sanctions à la hausse
merci nicolas landry depuis le sommet
européen qui se tient qui se tenait même
au château de versailles à l'événement
s'est clôturée après deux jours de
discussions à qui ont démarré ce jeudi
merci à vous nicolas et merci également
à michael et demi d'euros qui vous
accompagnait pour les moyens techniques
d'ailleurs sur ce sujet retrouver tous
nos reportages toutes nos interviews à
propros de à propos de ce sommet
européen de versailles dans l'édition
spéciale elle dit hier jeudi sur tv 78
aussi sur nos différents réseaux sociaux
avant de refermer cette émission est
bien les agendas du week end
est une idée de sortie solidaire pour
débuter à montigny le bretonneux la
municipalité organise samedi une grande
journée de collecte pour la population
ukrainienne c'est la haye deuxième temps
fort de la journée un rassemblement
citoyen sur le parvis de l'hôtel de
ville à 12h25 chanteurs de la chorale à
corinne yvon interprété plusieurs chants
ukrainiens pour l'occasion et puis idées
de sorties sportives pour terminer à
cette édition tout le week-end des
mureaux accueille les championnats de
france de cross-country c'est à lille de
loisirs du val de seine l'élite
hexagonale de la discipline sera
présente 3500 athlètes en tout sont
attendus et vous pourrez même vous
tester à la pratique avec une course
open de 6 km qui vous est proposé le
samedi matin et départ à 10h le retrait
des dossards se fait à partir de 8h et
la participation est gratuite
voilà c'est la fin de cette ut week-end
merci de nous avoir suivi la formation
locale qui revient lundi en direct et ce
à partir de 18h10 il a passé un
excellent week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]